Let us have the equation y = x + 3.
And I want to display all the ordered pairs of coordinates (x; y)
which satisfy this equation.
We've done this many times before.
So we draw our axes.
This is my axis y.
This is my axis.
This is my axis x.
And the equation is already in the form y = mx + b or
in the form of an angular coefficient and an intersection with Ou.
The intersection with Oy here is equal to 3,
and the angular coefficient (gradient) here is 1.
So this right will look like this.
We cross into (0; 3) - 1, 2, 3.
B (0; 3).
And we have a slope of 1, so with every 1 we move
to the right, we will go up with 1.
So the rights will look like this.
It will look like this.
This is a good approximation.
So the rights will look like this.
And do not forget that when I draw rights, every point of this
right is the solution of this equation.
The dot represents a pair of x and y, which
satisfy this equation.
When you take x = 5, you go on
the rights and you will see - watch you when x = 5 on
this right, y equal to 8 is the solution.
And it will lie on the right.
So this is the solution defined by this equation,
all pairs of coordinates that satisfy y = x + 3.
Let's have another equation.
Let's say we have an equation y = -x + 3.
And we want to depict all pairs x and y that are in charge
of this equation.
We can do the same thing.
This crosses also in 3, right there.
But its slope is -1.
So it will look like this.
Every time you move to the right with 1, you will
go down with 1.
Or if you move to the right many times, you will move
down as many times.
This is the way this equation will look.
Each point of this line represents a pair of x and y, which
will satisfy this equation.
Now if I ask you: is there a pair of x and y,
which satisfies both equations?
Is there a point or the coordinate that corresponds to the two equations?
Let's think.
Everything that satisfies this first equation is on this one
green right here and everything that suits that
purple equation, is the purple right there.
So what satisfies both?
Is there a point that is both right?
In essence, this is a point of intersection.
So in this situation, this point is on both lines.
And this is actually the point of crossing the axis y.
So point (0; 3) is both right.
This pair of coordinates or this pair (x; y) must respond
of both equations.
You can try it out.
When x is 0 here, 0 plus 3 equals 3.
It satisfies both equations.
So what we have just done in graphic form is a solution
of the system of equations.
The system of equations.
Let me write it.
System of equations.
And all this means we have several equations.
Each of them limits our x and y.
So in this case, the first one is y = x + 3 and
then the second one is y = -x + 3.
This limits it to a straight line in the plain, that
limits our solution to another
right in the xy plane.
And if we want to know the xs and ys that satisfy both simultaneously
of them, this will be the intersection of these rules.
So, one way to solve these systems of equations is yes
draw both lines, the two equations, and then see
their intersection point.
And that will be the solution of both equations.
In the next few videos we'll see other ways to
solving them, perhaps more
mathematical and less graphic.
But I really want you to understand the graphic
the nature of solving systems of equations.
Let's take another example.
Let's say we have y = 3x - 6.
This is one of our equations.
Let the other equation be
y = -x + 6.
And just like the last video, let's draw them both.
Let's draw the graphs of the two equations.
I'll try to do it as much as I can.
Let's draw them.
Here.
Let's draw a few ...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
And then 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
I just had to copy and put some millimeter paper here,
but I think it will work.
Let's draw this purple equation here.
The intersection with the y-axis is -6, so we have ...
let me make another division
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
This is y = 6.
And then the slope is 3.
So every time you move 1, you go up by 3.
You move right to 1, your move is 1,
you are rising 1, 2, 3.
That's 3, is not it?
1, 2, 3.
So the equation, the line will look like this.
And it seems I'm crossing into
(2; 0), which is correct.
3 in 2 is 6, minus 6 is 0.
Our rights will look something
just like that there.
That's right there.
How about these rights?
Our intersection with the y axis is plus 6.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And our slope is -1.
So every time we go 1 right, we go down with 1.
Go 1 right, move 1 down.
This will cross ...
when y = 0, x is equal to 6.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So, right there.
So this right will look like this.
I want the graph to get as accurate as possible.
We will ask the same question.
Which is the pair (x; y) that suits
both equations?
Okay, look here, this point will be.
This point lies on both lines.
And let's see if we can find out who this point is.
Just looking at the graph here, we seem to be in
1, 2, 3 and 1, 2, 3.
It seems that this is the same point out there that that
is a point (3; 3).
I only do it to check my drawing manually
graphics, so maybe it's not exactly -
let's check this answer.
Let's see if x is equal to 3, y is equal to 3, definitely
will meet both equations.
So, if you check it in the first equation, you get it
3 is equal to 3 by 3, minus 6.
This is 9 minus 6, which is really 3.
So, (3; 3) satisfies the above equation.
And let's see if it meets the lower equation.
You get 3 = -3 + 6.
-3 plus 6 is really 3.
So even with our hand-built graphics we were able to explore it
and see that we can find a point
(3; 3) which satisfies
both of these equations.
So we were able to solve this system of equations.
When we say a system of equations we have in mind
equations that have many unknowns.
They do not have to be, but are likely to have more than
an unknown one.
And you use each of the equations as a constraint on the variables
and you are trying to find the intersection of the equations,
to find the solution of each of them.
In the next few videos we will see different algebraic ways for
solving these systems, building their graphs and trying to
you find their intersections.